I am thrilled to be having to my left to
kick-off an hour that will finish with
Drew Brees of the New Orleans Saints one
of our longtime friends of this program
from the Kansas City Chiefs Pro Bowl
tight end Travis Kelce is here on the
show always good to be on a nice warm
round of applause right there it's a
nice warm day it's about 60 outside no
it is not
is that not warm it's very warm I just
did not know it was 60 degrees out the
sun's out so you wouldn't do the traffic
as well and the traffic is very smooth I
got here in seven minutes Oh Travis
killing rich Isaac block away but
traffic and weather together on the twos
here well done kick us out on our three
now I'll just say this you know you and
I have gone way back in my industry on
television you can tell which members of
the media have hit it hard when they
show up on television with a frog and
their throat with a little bit of a
voice that sounds Scratchy
so whatever enough you have a parrot and
have a very scratchy voice situation
Travis Kelce did you hit it hard
Thursday night you know what it was is
um we um I saw a Gucci man for the first
time I've ever seen Gucci man is that a
man who wears Gucci he had on Chanel
last night but yes I am turning 50 and
I'd like to think that I am somewhat in
the mainstream of popular culture but I
am unfamiliar with the work of Gucci
Mane okay so fill me in yeah he has
nothing to do with one my throat is like
really trying to figure out how I can
slide this by without not even anyone
even knowing it yeah I can barely do do
you need a lozenge you know just another
sip of coffee oh my gosh you on caffeine
it's definitely a prospect that I would
think would be a little dangerous you as
a caffeinated individual if you just
come correct when you only know one
speed Travis yeah I mean that's you got
to live it right alright what'd you
think of this season what do you how do
you think of it um honestly I
I mean looking back on it it was a fight
was an amazing season I enjoyed every
every bit of it up until the end and it
was a rollercoaster I think we grew
unbelievably as a team and Patrick
mahomes man he's a he's a hell of a
player
fun to play with and sure enough he's
about to take over the league if he
hasn't already I think he has I really
really do I think that obviously I'm not
telling any tales out of school that he
is the face of the 21st century of this
league the way that he throws the way
that he looks when he throws or when he
doesn't look when he throws is that do
you know when he's not looking at you
that he's going to throw to you um
because you have been the recipient I
think of the most no-look passes from
Patrick mahomes I feel like I've been
around I mean yeah I think I have
probably three or four of them where I
noticeably saw him not looking at me at
all when he threw the the only thing you
got to be aware of this where the other
guys are because you never know if he's
not looking you off or if he's no
looking somebody else off it kind of
sounds weird saying that no I know but I
followed you yeah I followed you but ya
know I mean the the biggest part is I
just said it all in my head again
no looking somebody else off but I
followed you yeah you can't say that on
television and raised yeah there's no
looking off right but it's weird it must
be weird for you um I don't think it's
that that weird I think it's a style of
play that um I mean over the course
obviously reps and things like that you
kind of understand that that's not
always gonna well be looking at you or
at the same time it's not just gonna be
a consistent over the top throw I mean
that's that's the biggest thing between
him and Alex is that Alex was very
consistent in how he threw the ball
right Pat is all over the place I mean
he eats sometimes is up here he's over
there sometimes things coming in like a
knuckleball sometimes you hit a
screwball on you slide the other way and
uh I mean I'm just adjusting to that and
always like focusing in on the rock all
the way into the hands ya know are you
making an arm motion your right arm is
underneath the bar connecting to our
microphone you're using your left arm
which he's done - yeah I mean it's crazy
the I mean
that's why fans love it and everything
you know everybody either picked him up
on their fantasy team or drafted him and
felt like that they were the genius
general manager and it I think that and
with your production and Tyriq Hill and
and the rest of the team it really is
just it was a dynamite team to watch and
I have a good time and I would have
loved to have seen you have a shot in
overtime yeah your thoughts on the
overtime rules Travis come I think I got
in a little trouble yesterday by saying
that I think it would be more fair
because it just comes off like I was
kind of blaming the rules for how it
ended you're an excuse maker
yeah yeah that's what it sounds like on
the twitter handle's but i there's
sixteen minutes in a game up until
overtime you can't blame the rules for
what they are I'm a firm believer that
you know what that first half is
something that I did not think I played
very well in and I could have done a
whole lot better that half so I think
just the Manning up in and saying that
it wasn't the overtime rule that is the
reason why we lost on a side note yes it
would be a completely way more fair if
both teams got a chance in overtime I'm
just I mean that's I mean that makes
sense but at the same time you know the
rules are the rules and uh we had to go
out there and play knowing that no I
know and the counter-argument and one
that we've made on the show too and it's
something that you can't say cuz it
would sound like you're throwing your
defense under the bus is that the
defense should stop somebody from
scoring a touchdown in order to continue
this was a team game I understand that
so but that said I think it would be
fair certainly in the playoffs in the
regular season now I know that the
problem would be you know the difference
you don't wanna have different rules for
the regular season of the postseason but
in the postseason you continue going
until somebody wins there's no tie so
automatically it's different o'seas
already I would like to see because like
what are we what are you saving yourself
for I mean like it's the season it's not
like you need to be rested for the next
week yeah even if you do go for in the
playoffs it's something that you'd
prefer to have the ability to counter
regardless of whether the first team
scored a touchdown or not
but if you did get a chance again though
let's say you put you out there while we
have this conversation even though I've
been talking to myself for the last
minute so let's to give your voice
arrest I think is that it would have
been advantageous to you to have all
four downs in a way that Brady wouldn't
have had in his first possession of
overtime know what I mean yeah if they
knew you knew you had to go for it on
fourth and ten from your own seventeen
Brady wouldn't have had it done that you
would add yeah I think um I think
everybody was waiting for that
opportunity to see Patrick moams try and
be a legend and just and just take over
the playoffs and the fan it's kind of
its kind of awkward I was thinking about
and I don't think it's the same way if
it's this is a reverse role the Chiefs
win the coin toss and we go down and we
score everyone's like aw man Patrick
mahalik Patrick mahomes you know he's he
led the team but and I don't think
everyone sitting there like well Brady
should have got another shot you know I
just think it's kind of awkward that
it's everyone was waiting for that
mahomes a legendary moment and they just
didn't get a chance to see it so the
headline of this is in case you know
Travis Kelce trying to be careful and
not get in trouble about the overtime
rules is now slagging on everybody who
thinks that the Patriots nobody cares
about them and I say that just as you
take a sip no I am I got I got
tremendous respect for them tremendous
respect for I think it's I think it's um
I think that's true though I believe
everyone really wanted to see my home's
a guy that they haven't quite seen in
that spotlight just get his chance I
know I would have I know I would have
but again the rules are the rules is
mahomes the MVP of the NFL yes no
questions about it didn't you saw
everybody else obviously mm-hmm well
what if I was he value able to your team
I would say when in terms of just a
teammate when adversity hit he was right
there at the front I'm trying to lead
everyone get everyone rally together
testing a few guys manhood and that was
respectable everyone him being what 23
years old guys that were 28 30
arguably ten years older than I'm rally
behind him when he did stuff like that
and I think that's I mean without him I
don't I don't see us getting that far in
the playoffs I think that's clear and
then on top of that the stats showed
every every reason why he's the VP I
mean 50 touchdowns maybe in his first
year I mean as unbelievable well was one
year ago this week that Alex Smith was
traded you know and I'm sure that was
something it was difficult for you to
swallow knowing how what you felt about
Alex Smith the me what I meant to this
team how long did it take from a homes
to get your trust respect do you think
the first day he walked in the building
I mean you could tell the guy was
special as a rookie yeah before even
before he even got the chance to be
named as the starting quarterback you
knew he was gonna be special you just
didn't know if he was gonna get in the
game be a little gun-shy or not be ready
for the moment which clearly he was um
saying he's always been a locker room
guy he's always been a friend a brother
to everyone on this team so I mean right
away you knew he was gonna mold um I
just was I was I've always been an Alex
Smith guy and I still am I think he's an
unbelievable player unbelievable guy and
I'm he spoken him lately
I haven't spoke to him lately now I saw
the the picture I think it was the
wizard he went to the Wizards game yeah
but it seems like he's getting out enjoy
I know it seems like he's not gonna play
in 2019 though I mean that's how badly
broken his leg was and he's such a good
dude man he really is one of the good
guys in this game is one of my favorite
man Travis Kelce here on the Rich Eisen
show do you think what what what do you
think of of the sport in the position
when we see Gronk here and we're
thinking it's his last game maybe
because everybody goes low on him
everybody goes low on you - yeah
football and football Oh
tackling um sorry about that season two
of catching up with calcium
we'll get to that in a second yeah man
can't wait Grunk yeah no I think I
personally Gronk will go down hopefully
I mean if he does retire I just want him
to be happy with what he's been able to
put out yes on the field I mean the guy
is unbelievable
player he'll go down as one of the
greatest tight ends ever play the game
he already has and he's still playing
and hopefully if he just feels
comfortable with the decision he makes
me cuz a lot yeah like you said a lot of
people are ranking on him right now for
not having that statistical season that
he's used to having and you know he's a
hell of a player okay how's your brother
doing so you don't great and doing great
is married
he's health are you an uncle oh there's
no kids no your brother that's not kid
you know not yet you're gonna be the
greatest uncle of all time gonna be yes
my brother my brother's probably going
to dislike hone how I will be an uncle
I'm gonna I'm gonna buy whoever it is a
pony yeah horse I don't know what I'm
gonna do well you got to do something
number Aegis you got to check with your
sister-in-law too you know
yeah Kylie Kylie's on board what do you
mean she's on board she's almost she
gets she gets it she gets who I am and
how I want to be uncle Travis it's gonna
be lit by the way that's a movie uncle
Travis going but I don't I don't want to
put any pressure on how how close your
brother is doing something like that
right what's your what's your scoop man
you you uh have you been caught his
Kelsey long yeah Chelsea's been caught
do you remember the the the catch that
wasn't a catch last year the catch no
catch yeah it was still it's still under
review unfortunately it's one of those
that you can't just make sense it went
to the league office so the you just
replayed that play in the game the catch
and Kelsey dating show the young lady
that has caught Kelsey is that the
winner of catching balls oh no no
she's long gone
ya know I'm not quite sure what she's
doing hopefully she's doing good okay
that's good my my lovely lady miss Kayla
Nicole is uh is actually over there
filming me right really Kelsey's been
caught oh say hi sweetie
hold on a second let's make sure that
she's on camera right here for catching
Kelsie so she I'm glad I was actually
yelling her the entire time yesterday is
that why you're all that's definitely
not the case what's definitely not the
case okay everybody there she is right
here right there on the rich Hodgins
show okay so she you have been
officially caught yes okay no no no ring
or anything like that but well okay I
enjoy her okay she enjoys me and she and
we live and we live cheers to Travis
Kelce okay much what so what's your
lovely girlfriend's name Kayla and
co-leaders I am
Kayla Nicole okay very good man all
Instagram yeah she said is that how you
guys met yes it is yeah Instagram
Instagram and business pleasure you name
it okay they got it on there man I just
post pictures of food in the backs of
the heads of my camera because I don't
want anybody to see their faces you got
everything on there and and the Rich
Eisen show you and I used Instagram
differently I mean again this were two
different people
what is Patrick mahomes his nickname in
the locker room cuz everybody's like we
call him show tom you did call him show
time right um I didn't call him show
time til everyone else like brought it
to to light and he said I think his
father had been calling him show time
right make sense but you can school all
right you caught a petty case - isn't a
tea cake Baker's man
okay bake me a cake as fast as you can
no look the cake roll okay I do like it
has that caught does he like it no yes
well you keep doing it because his pops
actually told me that he disliked it too
dislikes patty-cakes
yeah he's like come on with the patty
cakes on my are you right all right
sorry sir
did you know what I've been trying to
call him okay I told I told him this and
he has politely refused the petrel now
you're not just given that just as a
friendly no I thought it was gonna be
something way worse I don't know
Sherrill you're the patch rule and he
texted you because I was texting him
back because you know we're texts
buddies in the same way there's McVeigh
in Bella check our you know so I texted
him hey how about the patch Aloha don't
think I liked that one
I tried again when he called into the
show and he totally politely shined it
off because he's a very nice guy but
what do you say you give him it just
next time you see him hey Patra Patra
and see how it lookin in Union you text
me how he took it I will without a doubt
do that yeah patty-cakes
seemed very good good to see you Travis
Kelce who do you think wins this
football I think it'll end up being a
coin flip and New England Patriots will
win a figurative coin flip or will there
be an overtime coin flip you call your
shop right new way team I don't even I
think the maitre d away team huh
that means they get the coin flip they
get they call it heads or tails are you
are you high guesses are gonna call
heads yeah it's gonna be heads Tom
Brady's gonna take about four minutes to
go down the field what and what an
interesting what an interesting detail
tape okay Travis Kelce here on the Rich
Eisen show you can follow him on twitter
at t-- kelsey or on instagram killa
travitt slide into any DMS because that
kelsey has already been caught and no no
that's correct
right here on the Richard show round of
applause for Travis Kelce there you go
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience